Gro 4 is out and it's a pretty good AI
model, but there is going to be more
noise about this language model than
possibly any other. So hopefully I can
give you a little signal amid the chaos.
Let's boil things down to just 10 things
to know about the newest and possibly
smartest AI model. Point one is that
Croc 4 might just be the smartest model
around, at least according to the
benchmarks. In certain settings on high
school math competitions, it beats out
OpenAI's best model and Google's best
model. The same is true for a fairly
famous science benchmark, the Google
proof Q&A, where it again beats out
Anthropic's best model and Google's.
Likewise on at least one coding
benchmark, but Elon Musk went much
further saying about Gro 4 that quote
it's smarter than almost all graduate
students in all disciplines
simultaneously. That quote is of course
going to be picked up by everyone, but
it needs three important caveats. First
from me is that Grock 4 is still a
language model, which means it's still
going to be prone to all those
hallucinations you're familiar with.
It's not a new paradigm of AI. Second,
we have heard that kind of hype before,
notably from the Google DeepMind CEO
Demesis Saris almost 18 months ago
saying that Gemini 2 was better than
almost all human experts. amazing about
Gemini is that it's so good at so many
things. As we started getting to the end
of the training, for example, each of
the 50 different subject areas that we
tested on, um, it's as good as the best
expert humans in those areas. That was
an exaggeration then and Musk is
exaggerating now because real world
performance doesn't always match up to
benchmark performance. Expertise is way
more than answering multiple choice
questions. Hence the third bit of
context coming from Musk himself the CEO
of XAI saying that that quote about
being smarter than graduates was at
least with respect to academic
questions. Gro four is a postgrad level
in everything like it's it just some of
these things are just worth repeating
like Grock 4 is postgraduate like PhD
level in everything better than Ph but
like most PhDs would fail so it's better
that said I mean at least with respect
to academic questions point number two
is that I've been highly impressed by
Gro 4 but these benchmark results are
misleading for another reason note first
of all that the y-axis doesn't begin at
zero so these differences between the
models models are somewhat exaggerated
in terms of scale. XAI, makers of Gro 4,
selectively choose which models to
compare to. Notice in one recent high
school maths competition, Gro 4 heavy,
and I'll get to that later, way
outperforms Gemini Deepthink, that's the
soonto-bereleased Gemini 2.5 Pro Heavy,
if you like. But in this coding
benchmark, Live Codebench, Gemini
Deepthink actually outperforms Grock 4
heavy and yet is not in the chart. As
always then, when these model providers
show benchmarks, you've got to take them
with a grain of salt, especially when
the answers to the benchmarks are
available online. But none of that quite
explains Grot 4's brilliant performance
on ARK AGI2, a semi-private evaluation.
As you can see, this post on Twitter or
X has got almost 3 million views and is
climbing rapidly because this is known
to be a fairly rigorous test of
so-called fluid intelligence or IQ if
you like. And Gro 4 genuinely does beat
out other models. I've covered ARC AGI
in other videos, but suffice to say, Gro
4 can genuinely pick up on latent
patterns in your data. Of course, that
is of relevance to almost all
disciplines. Next, is there a benchmark
for how smart a model feels? Well, yes.
I tried to come up with one and it's
called simple bench. It's a test of
social intelligence, trick questions,
and spatiotemporal questions. Now,
because everyone is spamming the Gro 4
API, it's pretty tough to run the full
benchmark today, but I've run about 20
questions to get a pretty good
estimation. Take this question. It's a
bit of a spin on a common logic puzzle,
and Grock 4 actually sees through it.
That's actually the first model not to
pick the trap answer. Grock 4 will feel
smart, but of course, if you draw it out
of its comfort zone, for example, with
spatial reasoning, it can still fall
apart. In this question, in common with
all other models, Quark 4 doesn't notice
that the glove will simply fall on the
road. It also takes an extremely long
time to answer fairly often, which could
be a slight issue for many of you.
Having said all of that, I strongly
suspect that Gro 4 will be around the
top of my leaderboard on Simple Bench.
In other words, try not to be too
tempted to explain away all those
benchmark results just to benchmark
hacking. Now, that doesn't mean Grock 4
is worth $300 a month, but I'll come to
that in just a second because there's
one more benchmark I want to touch on,
and that is, of course, the grandiosely
named humanity's last exam in which
under certain settings, Grock 4 scores
over 50%, by far the best performance of
any model. However, you should know that
this is a knowledge intense benchmark
and therefore performance is heavily
dependent on the training data that goes
into the model. To give you just one
example, is it critical to your use case
that a model know about hummingbirds
having a bilateral paired oval bone?
Now, I sound cynical, but I think it's
actually really cool that models have
such an incredible knowledge base. And
so, genuinely, I will be using Grock for
a fair bit. I said at the time of the
release of that exam that it wouldn't be
humanity's last exam. Whether you happen
to have the requisite knowledge in your
training data isn't so much a marker of
how intelligent you are as a model. This
is not hindsight. On my Patreon in
September of last year, I called that
the exam would fall sooner than many
others with tools means that for
example, Grock 4 can write code to
perform certain computations. But what
is this Gro 4 heavy? Well, here's Musk
to explain
the with the GR 4 heavy. What what it
does is it spawns multiple agents in
parallel and uh all of those agents do
do work independently and then they
compare their work and they they decide
which one like it's like a study group.
Um and it's not as simple as a majority
vote because often only one of the
agents actually figures out the trick or
figures out the solution. um and and and
but once they share the the trick or or
or figure out what what the real nature
of the problem is, they share that uh
solution with the other agents and then
they compare they essentially compare
notes and then and and then yield uh
yield an answer. So that's that's the
the heavy part of GR. Now, long-standing
followers of the channel may note that
that is the exact premise of Smart GPT
that I released around 18 months ago,
which scored at the time a record
performance on the MLU, 89%. Ironically,
that exam was also authored by Dan
Hendris, who is the lead author of
humanity's last exam. And yes, I can't
resist plugging that Andre Karpathy
shouted out smart GPT. One last thing on
the benchmark that many might have
missed is that the textbased performance
of Gro 4 and Gro 4 heavy is extremely
good. But on the full benchmark, it's a
more modest improvement over say Gemini
2.5 Pro. So Gro 4 must do really quite
badly on the visual segment. In other
words, you might not want to rely on it
for decoding Roman inscriptions. Which
brings me, of course, to super Groheavy
for $3,000 a year or $300 a month. XAI
are promising new features will come to
super Groheavy like video generation in
October, but Gemini Ultra for a lower
price already has V3. Now, if your
pockets are deep enough, you'll just
subscribe to everything. But if this is
your only maxed out subscription, it's
hard to look past the much cheaper $20
Gemini Pro. Let me know, of course, in
the comments if you think it's worth
this amount and why. I'm open to being
persuaded. I just don't see it at the
moment. Just quickly, if you're a
developer, you'll know that Gro 4's
pricing is at the same level as Claude
for Sonnet, $3 input, $15 output, which
is a decent price for a Frontier model,
but again, there are much cheaper
alternatives. Next, if you did watch the
live stream, of course, Musk mentions
repeatedly that they have new features
and new models coming soon and that Gro
5 may be finishing training imminently.
However, we also get leaks this week
that Gemini 3 is coming and of course,
perennial leaks about GPT5 coming this
month. Now, it used to be the case that
we would then have to wait 6 months for
the actual release of the model because
of safety checks. Would a model help
with creating a bioweapon, for example?
But that all seems to have gone out of
the window at the moment. Which brings
me to this fairly wild quote from Musk
on safety.
Will this be bad or good for humanity?
Um it's like I I I think it'll be good.
Most likely it'll be good. Um Yeah.
Yeah. But I somewhat reconciled myself
to the fact that even if I if even if it
wasn't going to be good, I'd at least
like to be alive to see it happen.
So yeah.
So actually one
Yeah.
Next, and you might have been wondering
when I was going to talk about this, but
yes, of course, Grock 4 may suffer at
times from a similar issue to Grock 3 in
that it seems to get sudden urges to
praise certain historical figures or
focus on a country, for example, South
Africa. That behavior seems to have been
caused by this addition to Grock 3's
system prompt, which is that its
response should not shy away from making
claims which are politically incorrect.
If such a small change to the system
prompt causes such wild behavior, then
anything could happen with Gro 4. System
prompts aren't of course the only issue
for XAI. They are apparently burning
through $1 billion a month. either Grock
4 or Grock 5 almost needs to bring in
more revenue for XAI. Then of course
there is the awkward pollution point
because while it is crazy impressive how
fast XAI have caught up to OpenAI and
Google DeepMind bringing in the
generators necessary to get competitive
that fast did come at a local cost. And
if you thought it was wild how quickly
Mus XAI got up to 100,000 GPUs, well,
they're planning to bring an entire
overseas power plant to Memphis with 1
million AI GPUs to be powered. I'm going
to try to end on a positive though
because even though Mus said that Grock
4 couldn't be used to generate new
scientific discoveries just yet, I do
think there is an underrated point to be
made that's demonstrated by this game
made with the help of Grock 4 in just 4
hours. And that's that while models like
Grock 4 often struggle with current
techniques to solo generate new science,
what they are optimized for is making
existing science or code easier for you
to solo. We probably shouldn't
underestimate the impact of allowing
everyone to do much more on their own.
Then again, you probably shouldn't be
using Grock to analyze whether or not
you should vote for the big beautiful
bill. However, and if Grock 4 or Grock
5's edge comes from its access to X and
Twitter data, then at least for Grock
5's sake, let's hope that X can clean up
so much of the bot replies, spam, and
clickbait that's on there at the moment.
Thank you so much as ever for watching.
I am certain that this won't be the last
mention of Grock 4 on this channel. In
fact, I think I mention Grock in a
documentary coming up on Patreon. Either
way though, have an absolutely wonderful